er ist in frankreichsvorstadt Ghettos
groß geworden
Alibi Montana ist Rapper
Krawalle gibt es hier immer wieder sagt
er aber so heftig wie jetzt war es schon
lange nicht mehr Krise überall im Land
er fährt durch die Vorstädte Frankreichs
trifft Jugendliche Sozialarbeiter er
fühlt den Puls wie er sagt
[Musik]
der Zustand gerade gerade im Moment
es läuft nicht gut gar nicht gut schon
vor dem Drama mit Neil war es schlecht
jetzt ist es schlimmer
ohne ihn wären Dreharbeiten hier nicht
möglich Kamerateams sind nicht
willkommen
im Moment gibt es hier nur ein Thema der
Tod von heil aus Monte und die Unruhen
der letzten Tage SKB und Luxi sind beide
17 genauso alt wie der Jugendliche der
bei einer verweigerten autokontrolle
durch den Schuss eines Polizisten starb
jetzt haben sie Angst
die Polizisten reden oft schlecht mit
uns sie haben keinen Respekt vor uns
wir haben das Video gesehen wie der
Junge aus nächster Nähe erschossen wird
das hätte uns ja auch passieren können
der Polizist durfte das nicht wir müssen
uns doch Gehör verschaffen und zeigen
dass wir unzufrieden sind
so zeigen sie ihre Wut mit Gewalt auch
in Klischees
wurden öffentliche Gebäude angegriffen
Montana trifft seinen Cousin er lebt
hier es ist nicht das erste Mal dass
dieser vor Ort eine Gewaltwelle erlebt
verbrannte Autos gab es immer wieder
das ist die Realität hier das Auto
gehört vielleicht einem Familienvater
oder einer Mutter die es braucht um zur
Arbeit zu fahren um die Rechnungen zu
bezahlen aber die Jugendlichen denken
darüber nicht nach sie haben einfach nur
Hass
damals waren hier in Klischees zwei
Jugendliche bei einer Verfolgungsjagd
mit der Polizei ums Leben gekommen das
hatte eine Gewaltwelle ausgelöst wie
jetzt der Tod von Naila
ich verstehe die Jugendlichen von heute
bei uns war das damals genauso das hat
uns ins Herz getroffen und wir sind
einfach ausgerastet
wochenlang brannten die Vororte
Frankreichs die Welt schaute erschüttert
auf den Flächenbrand in den
vorstadt-ghettos der vor allem eins
gezeigt hat in den sozialen Brennpunkten
hat Frankreichs Politik seit Jahrzehnten
versagt Klischees
wir hatten alle die Montana ori und
seine Freunde damals schon getroffen in
der Eingangshalle des heruntergekommenen
Wohnblocks Löschen von
der Jugendliche der gestorben ist hat
hier gewohnt im ersten Stock einer wie
du und ich wie die die da jetzt spielen
zu verschaffen
wenn wir reden passiert nichts wenn wir
Autos anzünden kommen die Leute her wir
hatten keine andere Wahl
der konservative Nikolausi war damals
Innenminister wurde später Präsident und
kündigte einen marschallplan für die
bonjour an Erfolg hatte das nicht dann
kam francount wollte mit einem bornier
planen alles besser machen und war
genauso erfolglos
es ist immer dasselbe sagten sie damals
schon über zehn Jahre ist das jetzt hier
2023 heute brennen die Vorstädte wieder
die Krawalle sind brutaler als 2005 und
die Gewalt breitet sich viel schneller
aus
damals musste man auf die
Abendnachrichten warten um zu sehen in
klischeezu boah hat es gebrannt so gab
es woanders Krawalle mit einem Tag
Verzug heute siehst du in einer Sekunde
was in welchem Viertel passiert das
macht total viel aus
sie hatten eine typische vorstadtjugend
Gewalt und Drogen gehörten zum Alltag
wieso macht heute Jugendarbeit für die
stattliche
wir waren genauso unsere Eltern hatten
uns überhaupt nicht im Griff die Schule
haben wir geschmissen sie haben ein
Hauseingängen abgehangen waren bei den
Krawallen dabei heute haben wir uns im
Griff
die Stadt bietet hier Sachen an für die
Jugendlichen für die verschiedenen
Altersgruppen aber viele von ihnen sind
total unempfänglich dafür die wollen da
gar nicht erst hingehen
Montanas Job ist die Musik geworden Rap
das Leben der Straße er weiß genau was
das heißt denn früher war er Chef eines
dealerings
vier Jahre war er im Knast weil er auf
den Chef einer verfeindeten Bande
geschossen hatte Notwehr sagt er
Mordversuch sagte die Justiz im
Gefängnis fing er an Texte zu schreiben
das kam draußen gut an es ermöglichte
ihm einen neuen Start ohne
Drogengeschäfte als er Anfang der 2000er
wieder entlassen wurde
im Jahr 2007 nahm er uns mit zu dem Ort
wo er früher geliebt hat das Hochhaus
bei Sack in lakoneoff damals einer der
gefährlichsten Plätze Frankreichs hier
musste auch er sich anmelden
kannst du mich sehen
je näher wir kamen desto lauter wurden
die Pfiffe der Speer hier Aufnahmen zu
machen war gefährlich und nur mit Alibi
möglich
ich werde jetzt erstmal aussteigen und
mit den Reden die sind gerade dabei zu
Dielen ich muss denen das erklären das
sind die verschiedenen Bandenchefs die
rufen sich an und sagen was ist hier los
da ist Alibi mit einem Kamerateam die
tolerieren mich hier aber viele von
ihnen nervt das sehr
denn hier schaffte der Drogenhandel die
meisten Arbeitsplätze
wir trafen einen seiner Bekannten der
bereit war mit uns zu sprechen
mein Horizont geht genau bis zu dieser
Hauswand da vorne
genau das meine ich die Leute hier
wissen gar nicht dass sie sich in der
Welt befinden ihre Welt ist die Vorstadt
la Kunde
und den Konzerten mit der Musik mal ein
bisschen rausgekommen hier wirst du
schon als Kind mit Gewalt konfrontiert
das Schock dich nicht wir wissen gar
nicht mehr was gut und böse ist wir
machen schlimme Sachen und denken das
ist normal dabei ist das nicht gut das
ist unsere Erziehung deshalb sind wir so
man ist hier von Frankreich
abgeschnitten man ist leider von der
ganzen Welt abgeschnitten
2023 fast 20 Jahre später drei
verschiedene Präsidenten haben
inzwischen vorstadtpläne gemacht ein
paar Wohnblöcke wurden renoviert und
Griechisch super hat jetzt eine Trambahn
bekommen aber die sozialen Probleme hat
keiner wirklich in den Griff bekommen
hier haben Sie alle versagt bis heute
sagt Alibi Montana
ich glaube wir haben inzwischen zwei
Frankreichs ganz klar zwei Frankreichs
die sich gegenüberstehen und sich nicht
verstehen
dieses Problems ich habe den Eindruck
dass die Politiker das nicht verstehen
und sie liefern keine sozialen Antworten
darauf
und deshalb verwüsten die Jugendlichen
alles was die von ihnen ungeliebte
Republik Frankreich repräsentiert auch
wenn das teilweise ihre eigenen Familien
trifft und sie greifen die Vertreter
Frankreichs an Bürgermeister und
Polizisten
als wir eingegriffen haben waren das
keine Ausschreitungen das war Krieg
die Leute die uns gegenüberstanden
wollten uns töten
die stehen drei Meter weit weg werfen
große Steine auf uns Schießen mit
Granatwerfern werfen Molotow Cocktails
auf uns
töten
[Musik]
dieses Frankreich klammert sich an seine
Symbole
der amtierende Präsident Emmanuel macron
verspricht angemessene Lösungen denkt
über die Einschränkung der sozialen
Netzwerke im Krisenfall nach die
Situation spielt seinen politischen
Gegnern von der extremen Rechten in die
Hände Wahlkampf kostenlos ein
Rechtsradikaler Geschäftsmann sammelte
im Netz Geld für den Polizisten in
Untersuchungshaft 1,6
das zerreißt die Republik weiter und
heizt die Stimmung in den Vorstädten an
Alibi Montana versucht zwischen den
beiden Frankreichs zu vermitteln er
trifft sich im Moment täglich mit
bekannten die wie er aus den
Problemvierteln kommen oder dort
Aktionen betreuen
Amazon
er organisiert große Events für
Jugendliche aus ganz Frankreich
gemeinsam rufen sie zur Ruhe auf
wenn man vor seiner Haustür alles
zerstört dann bringt das nichts Gewalt
bringt nie etwas Gutes und wenn ich den
Jugendlichen einen Rat geben kann
beruhigt euch jetzt wo wir hier
miteinander sprechen wir hoffen dass die
Justiz ihre Arbeit richtig macht
Rap die Musik der Straße ist inzwischen
ziemlich erfolgreich auch über die
vorstadtgrenzen hinaus Radio Generation
ist im Zentrum von Paris zum Interview
eingeladen
ich erinnere mich genau als ich klein
war da habe ich seine Musik gehört er
war mein Idol hat eine ähnliche Karriere
hinter sich wie Alibi Drogen Knast und
dann hat er ein Restaurant eröffnet und
jetzt moderiert er die Abendshow bei
Radio Generation
der große Alibi Montana wie geht es dir
mein Bruder
super Ich freue mich total hier zu sein
wir fahren durch alle diese Viertel
durch viele Städte Frankreichs ich
spreche mit den Jugendlichen über das
was hier passiert ist aber wir zeigen
eben auch all die positiven Dinge die es
hier gibt
[Musik]
dann spielen sie Chris
den Song hat er 2005 geschrieben
er listet die Namen der Vorstädte auf in
denen es damals brannte man kann sich
fast eins zu eins auf heute übertragen
die Vorstädte bleiben ein Pulverfass
dass jederzeit wieder explodieren kann
[Musik]